that's right, right?
Let me tell you about some of the costs
when we fail to tap into our students' potential.
A McKinsey study showed that if in 1998
we could've closed our long-standing student achievement gaps
between students of different ethnic backgrounds
or students of different income levels,
by 2008, our GDP --
our untapped economic gains --
could have gone up by more than 500 billion dollars.
Those same gaps in 2008,
between our students here in the US and those across the world,
may have deprived our economy
of up to 2.3 trillion dollars of economic output.
But beyond economics, numbers and figures,
I think there's a simpler reason that this matters,
a simpler reason for fixing our system.
It's that in a true democracy,
like the one we pride ourselves on having --
and sometimes rightfully so --
a child's future should not be predetermined
by the circumstances of their birth.
A public education system should not create a wider bottom and more narrow top.
Some of us can sometimes think
that these things aren't that close to home,
but they are if we broaden our view,
because a leaky faucet in our kitchen,
broken radiator in our hallway,
those parts of the house that we always say we're going to get to next week,
they're devaluing our whole property.
Instead of constantly looking away to solutions like privatization
or the charter school movement to solve our problems,
why don't we take a deeper look at public education,
try to take more pride in it
and maybe use it to solve some of our social problems.
Why don't we try to reclaim the promise of public education
and remember that it's our greatest collective responsibility?
Luckily some of our communities are doing just that.
The huge teacher strikes in the spring of 2019 in Denver and LA --
they were successful because of community support
for things like smaller class sizes
and getting things into schools like more counselors
in addition to teacher pay.
And sometimes for the student,
innovation is just daring to implement common sense.
In Baltimore a few years ago,
they enacted a free breakfast and lunch program,
taking away the stigma of poverty and hunger
for some students
but increasing achievement in attendance for many others.
And in Memphis,
the university is recruiting local, passionate high school students
and giving them scholarships to go teach in the inner city
without the burden of college debt.
And north of here in The Bronx,
I recently researched these partnerships being built
between high schools, community colleges and local businesses
who are creating internships in finance, health care and technology
for students without "silver spoon" connections
to gain important skills
and contribute to the communities that they come from.
So today I don't necessarily have the same questions about education
that I did when I was an idealistic, perhaps naïve college grad
working in a detention center basement.
It's not: Can schools save more of our students?
Because I think we have the answer to that --
and it's yes they can, if we save our schools first.
We can start by caring about the education of other people's children ...
And I'm saying that as someone who doesn't have kids yet
but wants to worry a little bit less about the future when I do.
Cultivating as much talent as possible,
getting as many girls as we can from all over
into science and engineering,
as many boys as we can into teaching --
those are investments for our future.
Our students are like our most valuable resource,
and when you put it that way,
our teachers are like our modern-day diamond and gold miners,
hoping to help make them shine.
Let's contribute our voices,
our votes and our support
to giving them the resources that they will need
not just to survive
but hopefully thrive,
allowing all of us to do so as well.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)